[Music]
hello everyone
we will continue our discussion of
problems in this lecture also
so the first problem we are going to
address here is
with this physical setup and you note
that
this problem was just like a cantilever
beam as we've been discussing previously
but we have now made this problem
statically indeterminate and
it now becomes a different sort of
problem because of the presence of this
roller support here okay this is very
much a statically
indeterminate problem okay so had this
ruler not been present it would have
been just in just a simple cantilever
under uniformly distributed load and
that would have been statically
determinate
okay but now it is not so now
uh in the previous lectures we had been
concerned
with the direct application of
castigliano's theorem of deflections
we were interested in finding out
the deflections at certain points we
also used a certain trick using the
fictitious force method to find out the
deflection at a point
uh deflections as well as source slopes
at a point uh
where directly point forces or couples
will not be applied
but it was at the end of the day just
finding out the deflections
and slopes but now we invert the
question
and uh now we are interested for this
particular problem
in finding out the reaction force at
this end
okay or this end so let's say that at
this
end let's let's call this end a
okay so we ask the question that what is
the reaction force at the end a
okay now please note that
if we simply go by the method of statics
as we had learned in our undergraduate
days uh this particular problem
is not really tractable okay
uh i mean it is a statically indicative
indeterminate problem
so that's the indeterminancy associated
with it we can't find out the reaction
force we can't find out all the reaction
forces
uh associated with this problem now
let's see if we can do this using energy
methods
okay now there will be a certain danger
associated with it
which i will discuss uh consequent uh
subsequently
but for now let us try to see if we can
find out the reaction force
okay and the trick the overall
understanding or conceptual trick behind
it
is that you note that suppose okay
suppose we were to think of the reaction
force at this end like a point force
and then uh
we we try to think that what is the
deflection associated
uh with that force okay now of course
because of this physical setup we know
for a fact
that the deflection here is equal to
zero okay it has nowhere to go
so the deflection here is very much zero
so that is the that is the
key conceptual trick involved okay we
find out the reaction force at this
end uh using castigliano's theorem of
deflection
with the knowledge that the deflection
is equal to zero so previously we had
found out
that the the unknown deflection given a
certain
point force here we are finding out the
unknown point force
given a certain deflection but both we
are
but for both the cases we are going to
use the castigliano's theorem on
deflections
okay so with this overall understanding
uh
we proceed uh which we
just like before that we take a cut
section uh
maybe somewhere here
and we consider the
the part of the beam which is to the
right of this
cut section
let me consider it a little bit below
okay and uh
let me complete the free body diagram
for this
i have the distribution of forces
or the same intensity as before as shown
here
i now also have the reaction force
sorry i also have the reaction
force at this end okay
let's say we call this r
r for reaction force and uh
we'll also have the
the moment here and the shear force
okay so uh
as before uh almost
algorithmically we proceed uh by first
writing
the expression for the moment uh so
this sense is clockwise and the
contribution to the moment
due to this reaction force calculated
about an axis
uh which goes through this end
if we consider that this is our x let me
just write that down
properly so we consider our x from this
end
so this entire distance is x so
that will contribute rx but in a sense
which is anti-clockwise so this is minus
rx
next the contribution to due to this
distributed
load will be wx
that's the force effectively acting at a
distance x by 2 from this end
and the sense of the moment due to those
due to that
effective force will be in the in the
same sense as this
m so which is why we have this plus here
uh
this x by 2 is the effective moment arm
for this w
x force so this
is equal to zero
so this m is equal to
r x minus w x
squared by 2. now uh
if we consider the deflection at a if
the deflection at a
uh or if if you want to write
it in the so maybe
you can write it like deflection due to
r uh
in the direction of r so that will be
using car significance theorem
uh zero to l m
by e i del m
del r
dx now please note that
earlier when we were when we had
artificially introduced the fictitious
force
we had evaluated this entire integral
for the fictitious for the value of the
fictitious force equal to zero
but now the knowledge that we have is
that uh
we don't have any knowledge about this
right-hand side but we do have the
knowledge about the left hand side
as we had mentioned earlier that this dr
that is actually equal to zero
okay because this dr is the deflection
at this end a
okay that is equal to zero so
uh
we evaluate this integral
this is rx minus w
square by 2.
divided by e i and del m del r just
gives us
x dx
okay so uh from this
we have 0 is equal to
[Music]
l this is
r x square minus w
x cubed by 2
divided by e i d x
and this is going to give us
let me just over here
0 is equal to well this e i will is not
going to contribute anything because i
can just multiply throughout
by e i uh so this is just
r x cubed by 3
minus w
x to the power 4
by 8. this entire thing
under the limits 0 to l
and that of course is 0 equal to
r l cube by 3
minus w l to the power 4 by 8 so overall
what i have for
r is 3
wl by 8
okay and you please note that this is
indeed dimensionally correct
because w has the unit of newton per
meter
so w times l is
actually having the unit of newton and
this reaction force r
has the unit of must have the unit of
newton
okay now regarding the
so this is our answer as we have been
asked to find out reaction force at the
end a
now regarding the danger that i was
alluding to earlier
uh you please note that this entire
method it works for statically
determinate problems
okay but it is not going to work for
statically
uh for so sorry this method is going to
work for statically indeterminate
problems
it is not going to work for statically
determinate problems
and you can take a quick look uh i mean
uh
so so we'll discuss this uh after the
next uh
after the next example but let me just
write it as a fair warning here
uh so so maybe with
the red sign and the skull symbol okay
so there's a very very big danger
okay
rather graphic warning here but i hope
this will help you to to remember it
always with this graphic warning
that
do not use this method
[Music]
or
statically determinate problems
[Music]
okay all right let's move on to the next
uh uh which i will not
solve in as much detail but uh it will
give us a good
uh understanding of
of another variety of problems that
could occur
so the situation is like this we again
consider
a beam
but this time this beam is
is uh constrained or attached
to two walls at the two ends so at the
at both the ends it is fixed
okay
sorry it's very bad
okay that's a little better
okay so this beam is attached to both
the walls
or clamped at both the walls and we have
a point force acting
vertically downward like this
the entire length of the beam is l okay
so let me not clutter it okay you
understand the length
l uh of the beam as it is in all the
problems earlier but
more importantly this distance
this distance here this is
a from the left end
okay and
what we are asked here uh is to
determine the reactions
meaning both the forces at the moments
and the two ends
okay so
so again you note that had this
beam not been clamped to this wall this
would have been a simple cantilever beam
and that would have been very much a
statically determinate problem
but now due to the uh to do the extra
rather unnecessary support of this of
this
wall this is no longer a statically
determinate problem
it is a it is a statically indeterminate
problem
all right so how do we go about uh
finding this thing so uh what we'll do
is
um we'll
we'll try to find out the reactions and
that is the forces of the moments
uh at this at this left end okay
so
let's draw this
sorry
just draw it like this
okay what i have done here
is basically i've taken a
cut section here
okay and
this is m here i
also have a
v
maybe this can be drawn a little bit
better
and note that at this end
it is this m
naught and this r
naught which we wish to find out okay so
this r naught and this m naught
ah they are not known uh
and of course we have this externally
applied
load
so this is of magnitude p
okay so as before we write down the
expression for m
so this is
so this m is this m
and that is in the anticlockwise sense
so the so when we write down write down
the entire movement balance
uh the contribution from this will be
with a minus sign
minus m naught and if we take the
contribution from this
r naught about an axis which passes
through this end
it is going to give us a moment which is
r naught times x
but again in the clockwise sense which
is opposite to this sense of
this anti-clockwise of m and finally
for this force p again uh
the moment about an axis which is passes
through this end
will be p
times x minus a but
you note that
this thing is going to get activated
only for x
greater than a okay so this is h
into x minus a so i must mention
that we are going we are calculating our
x from this
end
[Music]
huh
and what is the sense of this movement
so it comes with a plus sign
um let me just check
so this distance is x minus a that is
fine
and that is the movement term so uh so
yeah
so that also has the has the
anti-clockwise sense
same as this m and this entire thing is
equal to
zero all right now i'm not going to go
through with the detailed steps of this
but you note that unlike the previous uh
problem where we were interested in
finding just
one unknown reaction force
here we we do not know the r naught
we do not know the m naught as well so
in order to find out these two unknowns
we need two equations
and uh the clue here is that
because this end is clammed we know from
physical considerations and our
under in our undergraduate studies that
the deflection here is going to be zero
not only that the slope here is also
going to be zero
okay so based on those two facts uh we
can use
the castigliano's theorem uh in inverse
using both the gaussian serum rather and
the coronary to the castigliano's
theorem involving the slope
to find out uh the two required
equations which can be solved
simultaneously to find out the unknowns
m naught
and r naught so let me just write down
those uh
the things that we need so it's like
this that
the deflection d
due to this r naught
this is going to be integration 0 to
l m by e i
del m del r naught
dx and you note
that this thing is going to be 0 from
physical consideration
similarly the theta
[Music]
m naught that is integration 0 to l
m by e i del m
del m naught d x and again this is going
to be 0
from physical considerations so if you
just substitute the expression for m
and here so you'll get fairly long
expressions here you can
can do that uh you can you can
do the algebra on your own uh solve them
simultaneously
and find out the the answers so let me
just write down the
and the answers for you here so for r
naught
now you will obtain after solving
you will obtain r naught is equal to
[Music]
p times l minus a square
l plus twice a
divided by l cube
and you know that this is indeed
dimensionally correct okay so this is
uh having the unit of meter square this
is meter so that's meter cube and the
denominator also
you have meter cube so at least it is
dimensionally correct
and for m naught we are going to have
minus p l minus
a square
times a divided by
l square and again you note that this is
indeed dimensionally correct because
this is m
square in the denominator you have m
square and this
m remains so this is newton uh metered
and that is the unit of m naught so at
least again it is dimensionally correct
so that this is uh
these are our answers now going back to
that danger that we had
mentioned in the previous problem you
please note
that uh i mean this this thing that
danger will be immediately evident
here okay so
uh you see uh
suppose this beam were not clamped at
this end
okay suppose this beam were not clamped
at this end
and given a question like this
that determine the reactions that is
both the forces and the moments
suppose we naively proceed exactly like
this
okay suppose we take a cut section here
uh
we consider this m this unknown m naught
and r naught
uh and we proceed like this so there is
absolutely nothing
which is stopping us from proceeding
like this even if
this beam was not clamped at this end
okay so that is for the case of the
simple cantilever problem
so because if we press time if we
proceed like this
we'll end up with these answers again
because the algebra
is going to be exactly the same nothing
changes but you note
that if for a simple cantilever problem
you
obtain these answers then definitely
these are going to be wrong because you
know that if you just
apply statics okay as you have
all learned in our first year mechanics
the reaction force at this end it is
simply p
and the moment the magnitude of the
moment is simply p
times a so these answers
are definitely wrong for a simple
cantilever problem
okay so uh
and the simple cantilever problem the
the the whole issue here is that
the simple cantilever problem uh that is
without the presence of this
uh clamped end that would be a
statically determinate problem
so as we had mentioned earlier we are
not supposed to use this
this method for those kinds of
statically determinate problems
okay all right so with that
on that note i will i will end this
lecture thank you very much
you